if you're keen to have a say on what
games you get for free with your
PlayStation Plus subscription that's now
a thing you'll be able to vote on soon
after an image leaks to neogaf last week
sony officially announced the vote to
play program which will let you have a
say on what games you want to see
release for free through playstation
plus plus members will soon be able to
cast a vote for one of several ps4 games
which will be included in the coming
month instant game collection the top
game will be released for free while the
games that didn't win will be sold at a
discount currently September is looking
to be when this process will start the
leaked image indicated that the free
games in the first poll will include
zombie Vikings a mellow and grow home
which is interesting considering grow
home hasn't actually been confirmed for
consoles it's worth noting however that
this leak came from the UK and the games
could be different for the US as they
often are which of these games will get
your vote for all the latest on boat to
play and everything else that matters in
gaming be sure to stay tuned the games
but